et combien de temps cela vous a-t-il pris pour certaines
chansons d'Andy Warhol et 15 chansons environ 10 jours
saviez-vous que les chansons de Drella
perdaient dit avec Johnny ne peuvent fonctionner que
tous les 20 ans je ne savais pas qu'il avait
dit ça  C'est étrange
que tu perdes Berlin et ton Paris 1919
tes meilleurs albums sont pour le velours
underground ce ne sont pas des albums de rock and roll
ouais j'aime Berlin je ne sais pas ce que Lou en
pense mais j'admirais les moches
n'était-ce pas terrible de continuer  travailler quand
tant de gens considéraient que tu avais produit
ton chef-d'œuvre avec le velours
underground non je ne regrettais aucune
des choses du monde je veux dire regarde ce qui
s'est passé et si je savais
que nous nous reverrions ou pas je
ne sais pas  mais je pense qu'il y avait tellement
de choses qui n'ont pas été
terminées que si nous en avions l'occasion, je
savais que nous prendrions vraiment le
taureau par les cornes et ferions beaucoup de choses. Je
pense toujours que vous pouvez faire beaucoup comme
ce que feraient les artistes.  vous aimez produire
ce Bob Dylan ce que vous  ce serait un prochain
album c'est une autre collaboration
avec brian eno et c'est avec une collaboration rock and
roll on utilise la
section rythmique des Neville Brothers et ce sera un
rock and roll très simple